on est là pour continuer l'organisation
des neuvièmes jeux des îles qui vont
vers l'est à la réunion en 2015 donc
c'était les représentants des 10 des
sept îles participantes où on a statué
sur un certain nombre de points pour
monter en puissance dans le dorset
organisations grecques la nouvelle
décision c'est qu'on on est sûr qu'on
n'aura pas plus de 2000 personnes
puisque on a un problème d'hébergement
haut de la thur bonne nouvelle une
mauvaise pour l'organisation c'est une
bonne nouvelle parce qu'on avait
quelques craintes puisqu'on n'avait pas
déjà le retour des différentes
délégations et on se disait si chacun
augmenté partie pas tout on ne pourra
pas tenir donc il faudra faire
donc ça on s'est mis d'accord maintenant
au 28 julien on aura le détail par
discipline dans ses différents
territoires ce qui prend à donner aux
ligues la possibilité de mettre en place
l'organisation pour les rencontres et
également ce qui a eu comme décision
c'est que on a confirmé à aux comores la
mise en place des jeux de 2009 sous
réserve d'une commission qui se rendra
en mars 2015 sur le territoire des
comores pouvoir ou sonné pour
l'organisation et comme notre prochaine
réunion du qui j'ai prévu les 13 et 14
mai à ce moment là nous pourrons statut
et d'une manière définitive sur la
communication de des jeux puisque
certains nous questionnent mais certains
pensaient même que le jeu allait se
tenir là cette année au mois d'août nom
un logo à nîmes
ça va permettre de visualiser et
d'entendre une musique que j'espère les
gens vont retenir en disant c'est steam
je me rappelle ça va être c'est l'hymne
des jeux de 2015 à la reine